ich bin entsetzt wie wir behandelt
werden dürfen sie schützen Juden in
diesem Land selektiv die Angst vor
jüdischen jüdisches Leben in Deutschland
frei zu leben ist zurück eindeutig und
jedenfalls meine Haltung ist nicht dass
jüdisches Leben sich nur in Synagogen
abspielt sondern genau wie sie es gesagt
haben in Restaurants in Musik
Veranstaltungen auf den Straßen und im
Grunde auch gar nicht nur als jüdisches
Leben sondern überall wo Juden
selbstverständlich mit dabei sind und
und diese Selbstverständlichkeit
entweicht uns gerade die polizeilich zu
schützen mit den Mitteln des Staates ist
Pflicht aber es natürlich schon kein
freies Leben mehr wenn überall nur
Polizeischutz freies Leben ermöglicht